so eine jukebox hat doch charakter an
der kann man noch richtig rumschrauben
wolfgang heckl liebt diese alten kästen
sammelt sie und vor allem repariert sie
der generaldirektor des deutschen
museums in münchen ist ein begnadeter
tüftler ein mann mit mission
wir sollen wieder mehr selbst hand
anlegen an den dingen des alltags
es gibt nichts gutes außer man tut es
könnte man auch sagen als grundsatz für
die reparatur kultur man tut es selbst
oder man lässt es tun
aber der reparatur da sollten wir uns
wieder zu wenden
gar nicht so einfach leider ist nicht
jeder mit zwei rechten händen geboren
viele aber mit zwei linken zusammen
reparieren ist das gebot der stunde so
genannte repair cafés sind die orte wo
sich tüftler und laientreffen heile
machen das schon tot gesagt war das ist
der letzte schrei im streben nach
nachhaltigkeit als hauptstadt der
bewegung geht berlin
hier gibt es die höchste dichte an
stützpunkten nur mut schallte es in
allen straßen die scheu nehmen dass man
auch mal reingucken können reparieren
heißt auch rebellion gegen den geplanten
verschleiß was wir kaufen gibt oft nach
zwei jahren den geist auf
wer selbst reparieren kann ist da am
längeren hebel
als er eine art vorkämpfer in der armee
der reparatur gültigen ja wir haben so
etwas wie technikkompetenz verloren ja
sie sind industrie analphabeten geworden
so sagen dass andere literaten
das heißt wir erleben hier dass wir
immer mehr vergessen die dinge gehen die
wir mit händen machen wollen
der mensch hat hunderttausende von
jahren erfolgreich handwerk betrieben
erst in den letzten jahrzehnten hat er
sich das wegwerfen antrainiert doch
umkehr scheint möglich ich beobachte
dass die handwerkskunst auch bei jungen
leuten plötzlich wieder im kurs steht
nicht nur flicken sondern auf werten bis
es mir vom leibe fällt so heißt das
atelier mit diesem vielversprechenden
credo
hier ist der kunde nicht nur könig kunde
selber wird auch zum mit designer und es
müssen sehr gute schneider und sehr gute
designer sein die dann mit den kunden
gemeinsam gutes design entwickeln also
sechs ihn es ist extrem wichtig und wir
nennen das eben auch wach küssen
ja reparieren ist sexy reparieren und
dabei ab cycle neudeutsch für besser
machen neue kleider haben keine
geschichte alte hingegen schon
und wenn sie mal kaputt gehen macht man
aus der not eine tugend
ich habe hier einfach den passenden
stoff ausgesucht den abgesteckt und dann
richtig als komplettes teil eingesetzt
es ist eben nicht das gleiche sich etwas
neues anzuschaffen
wir sollten die dinge wieder
wertschätzen liebhaben erhalten
mir tut es wirklich leid dass ich früher
viele sachen weg gegeben habe weil mir
jetzt viel erinnerung eigentlich fehlt
wolfgang heckl hat die bibel der repair
bewegung verfasst die fordert nicht nur
kaputtes wieder ganz zu machen
es steht noch mehr auf dem spiel wir
sehen uns wieder ein wenig danach selbst
alltag in einer umgebung die ich selbst
bestimmen kann auch ein wenig auch als
gegenbild zur globalisierung eigene
dinge zu gestalten zu erfinden
herzustellen zu basteln zu bauen zu
reparieren also ohne handwerk haben wir
keine voraussetzung letzten endes auch
hochtechnologie zu gestalten
die hochtechnologie ist es auf die die
reparatur szene der schweiz setzt fab
labs heißen die orte wo bastler und
technikfreaks zusammenkommen ich glaube
es verbleibe für felix see zukunftsmusik
und und das ganze 3d drucker ist noch
nicht konkret aber dann kreativ machen
so einfach ist das innerhalb von 30
minuten erklärt wie es irgendein objekt
fahndungsdruck objekte die nicht mehr
erhältlich sind kann man mithilfe
futuristischer geräte neuerdings selber
machen
zurück in die zukunft ist es lustig
abbruch
und das so wobmann jugend forscht
wer weiß vielleicht setzt sich die
schweiz um noch an die speerspitze der
reparatur bewegung
die schweizer sind es gewohnt zu basteln
zu hause zu reparieren jeder hat
sozusagen ein schweizer messer sein
werkzeug seine werkstatt zu hause der
muss nicht unbedingt in ein café ob in
der mannschaft oder jeder für sich
es besteht ein tiefes bedürfnis wie der
mut zu schöpfen
sich selber etwas zutrauen machen sich
nicht alles gefallen lassen
all das hat einen namen reparatur